wenn mein name ist sie gerät nicht
willkommen wir heute im zweiten video
ich weniger alleine sondern will
bestimmt nicht heran
mit nachgemachten welt nur weil es mal
macht besitzt eine den handys wird dabei
ist diese kontrolle mit ihrem spiel und
wo man diese drohung hat und dann haben
wir uns gedacht ok gibt es ja wie viele
spiele er gibt der wirklich noch nicht
viele spiele für die konsole und das
einzige was man das auf andere weise in
den video packen kann ins eines weiß ich
dachte wir haben da doch was keiner
weise dazu aufgenommen das bin ich und
der betreibung verlinken lange rede
kurzer sinn mache davon jetzt drei
spiele und wer davon mehr gewonnen hat
heute komplette video rolle
[Applaus]
das erste spiel was riskieren denn es
fördert die weder die etwaige
eingeblendet wurde weil der platz am
ende auf wir haben keine chance wir
brauchen einen wirklichen bürgerschützen
besteht weil wir daraus dass wir einfach
stark rücken 100 m fertig wachsen in der
hand liegt brände hat bestehen um
überhaupt wieder spielen gegen einer
tischlerei in die augen schauen wer
anfängt
leichter ist der kreml ball im feld ist
für mich meine damen und herren der
[Musik]
[Applaus]
frächter spieler
es ist nicht schlimm diese schlechte ich
befinde mich gerade durchschnitt vor dem
video mir bitte jetzt erst bewusst was
das jetzt für eine asoziale aktion von
backwaren spüren natürlich weiter aber
erstmal hier ganz kurze information was
ich machen werde und zwar möchte ich mag
so hinstellen dass er passen die kamera
kommt und er wird das schamlos aus um
einen punkt zu machen aber die plätze
[Applaus]
nur so kann eckpunkte ich mich machen
und fasst das schreibt man alle die
kommentare märkten ein schlechter
spieler danke was erklären
[Applaus]
400 euro aufgegeben
platz und liegt mit dem einem spiel
[Musik]
können wir die haushalte über youtube
gerade gefordert
bauern dürfen verkehren höheren welten
gegenüber und nach euch bereit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
drei wochen später im verband weiter
fahren spur
[Musik]
da wird sicher geltende strenge der zu
recht sportlich
[Applaus]
gleichen farbe
ich hab die hand im spiel hat mich
gewundert weil die menschen dort habe
ich aufgewacht also ist insgesamt
gewonnen
wenn er den beutel verpacken damit drei
weitere wenige topf auf jeden fall mal
vorbei um das leben der opfer aufgeteilt
noch mehrere mini allen stücken wenn die
big heute wird das noch mal machen und
doch war die andere weniger entlocken
hat auf jeden fall leichter und weil den
wir im video
dort bittet er ist genau die einwände
wenn ihr darauf wie könnte man den kanal
kostenlos abonniert hat keine videos
mehr noch ein schauer eingeblendet hier
unten ist ein weiteres video und
bekräftige zwar auch eine chance